hello everyone and welcome back to
versus for a very special episode
featuring a matchup we've all been
salivating for since the very inception
of this show it doesn't matter who's
competed beforehand robocop versus
terminator nicole kidman versus laura
dern chef boyardee vs hamburger helper
which i'm told we will do at some point
all roads have led to this gaggle of
galactic goliath we have for you today
alien vs predator yeah it's been a movie
and before that a comic book run and
before that two standalone franchises
that first mixed when we saw a glimpse
of a xenomorph skeleton on a predator
ship and unlike some of their crossover
events in the past this versus episode
pitting the entire alien franchise
against the totality of predators will
have a definitive winner two actually if
you count both the victoria's species
and you the audience
[Music]
alien took flight in 1979 predator first
hit earth in 1987 and ever since the
mass populous has been begging to see
these two go at it tent ot then in 2004
we got an avp movie that was followed by
a sequel then we got some more
stand-alone adventures and all of them
are being tossed into the vitamix today
to settle the score once and for all or
at least until ridley scott makes
another alien flick or arnold sees fit
to battle one more predator stick around
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
oh the humanity round four hunting
season is open and then we'll do a wild
card round that could involve anything
from cooler creature look to deadlier
blood to who would win more olympic
events let's see i'd have face huggers
in power walking predators in javelin
and for some reason i feel like
xenomorphs could easily win a hot dog
eating contest which i've been told is
currently not an olympic event to which
i'll reply just you wait
well the way it is over to see two of
the most popular interstellar travelers
in the history of hollywood go at it one
team will emerge victorious after a
worthy battle for the other it'll be
game over man game over man it's game
over let's get it on round one box
office
if you weren't aware prior to enjoying
this program yes there's been two films
that saw predators and aliens battling
it out accurately titled alien versus
predator and even more conveniently
known as avp which i always thought
those little bumper stickers were
referring to until i realized that that
was some disney park designation
oh well a versus p was a hit out of the
gate back in 04 and they would amass a
total of 173 million dollars around the
world requiem was a sequel and it hauled
in 129 million bucks and now we already
have our first fun fact of the day at
the time of alien vs predator's release
it became the highest grossing opening
weekend ever for a film with a black
female as the lead senate lathan
[Music]
that record has since been usurped by
jordan peels us but still a valuable
historical footnote and speaking of
history let us now go all the way back
to the late 1970s twas the final year of
that decade that gave birth to alien and
possibly the greatest tagline in film
war so maybe in space no one can hear
you scream but here on earth audiences
everywhere were terrified of the sci-fi
horror blend that taught us all if
you're having chest pains pepcid ac may
not be the remedy you need alien took in
185 million dollars on this planet and
its cleverly titled sequel aliens did
183 million dollars worth of business
alien 3 and alien resurrection kept the
pace by staying above 160 million each
and then in 2012 prometheus set the
all-time high mark for either franchise
when it earned 402 million bucks the
most recent film in the series alien
covenant also did well with 239 million
in earth bucks to its credit predator
kicked off in 1987 and had a huge
advantage right out of the gate
literally it would star some guy named
arnold as he was hitting his career
prime
knock knock the schwarzenegger factor
got the film to within a whisper of 100
million bucks landing at 98 million and
while predator 2 nabbed only 55 million
dollars 2010 saw a resurgence when
predators hit to the tune of 127 million
dollars followed by 2018's the predator
making 159 million and helping bruce
wayne with what to title his next
standalone venture all told predator
films have collected 741 million dollars
on our planet making for a perflic
average of 123 million bones but those
pesky aliens have raked in 1.63 billion
in cold hard cash which gets their per
film average to 204 million dollars over
200 mil and we still can't greenlight
another one of these movies come on
hollywood i'm sure the predators are
down to pop in they're available and
always good for a scrap but they come up
short here in round one in space you
evidently can hear the sounds of cash
registers and it's team alien that gets
the win here and they're up one to
nothing excellent work everybody round
two tomato meter slash audience score
alien not only had an eight year head
start on predator it also had the
benefit of two films in the franchise
debuting on the big screen before arnold
and carl weathers ever shook hands you
son of a
perhaps that also helped make those
first two alien entries feel i don't
know fresher let's ask the tomato meter
first you know for a species that drools
from multiple mouse all the time the
alien films clean up fresh pretty well
alien and alens are both certified fresh
at 98 and 97 percent respectively my god
i knew they were good but those are
godfather like numbers how the first two
predators do you ask well let me caution
all you folks on team space hunter that
part one has arnold part two has gary
busey and while we love both those stars
dearly the critics have had some other
feelings about them throughout the
decades
oh my but it's good news out of the gate
as the inaugural predator is resting at
a solid 81 percent fresh but despite
having danny glover in the cast for part
two 1990's follow-up is only a 30
percent rotten leading me to surmise
that most critics didn't care about that
awesome easter egg inside the spaceship
at the end that's the xenomorph skeleton
it's a trophy for predators and proof
that this could indeed be a shared
universe despite that excitement the
next two aliens found their way to
rotten territory as well alien 3 landed
at 45
and resurrection couldn't get back up to
fresh settling it is still respectable
54 okay do you want to know what the two
lowest rated flicks for either sporting
b-star was that it's the movies that
featured them both alien versus
predators at 21 and requiem is at 12
even though it had a predator morph or a
xenomortator i'll get the nomenclature
right and be back to you but it was
awesome the two properties did return to
freshville each once they went their
separate ways 2010's awesome predators
is at 65
and 2012's thinker prometheus landed at
73 covenant is also fresh at 65
unfortunately for the most recent
predator gig it wasn't as fruitful the
predator is rotten at 33 so aliens
strike first here as their per movie
tomato meter averages 58
against predators 40 that's a solid
victory for the facehuggers but what's
that sound
good god that's the audience scores
music predator improves upon its first
four entries on this metric including an
87 for part one 44 for part two and a 39
for avp unfortunately the audience
walked into a different movie than i saw
in 2010 because the awesome predators
again i'll remind you it's awesome it's
somehow rotten on the audience score 52
are y'all sure you saw the same flick
because uh the one i took in had adrian
brody being a total badass on a distant
planet i give it 10 out of 5
distant planets
then i'm just one man and it's my job as
the messenger to not be shot or impaled
or eaten when i report that the average
audience score for team predator is
still rotten but it's improved up to 47
so you're telling me there's a chance i
can make it unfortunately for them the
alien folk have also improved their
audience average up 58 and a quarter
percent tends to be the case when both
alien and aliens are tied at 94 percent
my goodness people love those first two
movies you know call me crazy i think
ridley scott and jim cameron have a
future in this business they also
competed in adverses against each other
last season you want to know who won i
don't remember but they both lose to
tony scott ridley's brother that dude
directed top gun one year and beverly
hills cop two the next game over indeed
well the game is still on here but the
round itself is as toasted as ellen
ripley was at the end of alien 3. is it
too soon come on it's been three decades
and the movie wasn't even that good
i know i know david fincher directed it
so everyone is trying so hard to like it
but to quote judge judy yeah
despite alien 3 the xenomorphs do take
round 2 and place the predators squarely
on the robes because they're losing 2 to
nothing
round 3 oh the humanity yep just like in
the transformers flicks or the jurassic
park movies we do need to have some
level of humanity to keep the action
grounded and relevant to us earthlings
luckily that necessity has blessed us
with two of the great action leads of
all time sigourney weaver as ellen
ripley and of course you guessed it from
predator gary busey of special agent
peter keys i'm kidding it's arnold
schwarzenegger as dutch shaffer i'll
take care of him
no
let him go did you know that was his
last name because it is busy's pretty
great in predator too though but let's
start with 1979 and ellen ripley who is
much more than just a protagonist with
her back against the wall of a spaceship
her fight-or-flight instinct was to
engage in mortal kombat with an
otherworldly assailant and in the
process she became far more than just an
intrepid cosmos explorer she was a
cinematic pioneer who showed the boys
that women can be just as strong even
braver and as wily when it comes to
saving the day some dudes had to learn
that lesson the hard way let's just pour
your beer out right now for harry dean
stanton and john hurt in the first film
and that oily slime ball paul ryser is
the corporate lackey in aliens if
sigourney weaver was note perfect as a
reluctant savior in her signature
franchise predator could not have found
a better more willing or more
able-bodied opponent than arnold s the
owner of multiple mr olympia titles
schwarzenegger had found a home in
tinseltown playing legendary heroes like
conan the barbarian and cold-blooded
cyborg assassins like the terminator but
all his skills muscles and budding
acting chops reached new heights with
predator him and his team were dropped
into the jungle facing an unknown enemy
and it took every ounce of dutch's guile
to survive by the skin of his teeth or
better yet the mud-coated skin of his um
well his entire body was pretty kicked
in mud but if sigourney and arnie both
came out of the gates firing i give the
early edge to weaver because she kept
coming back for more and maybe that's
why the alien franchise saw more
consistent returns at the box office but
with the added xenomorphs and aliens we
also compounded the cool human soldiers
hudson and hicks played respectively by
bill paxton and michael bean went both
militaristic know-how and a sense of
humor to the proceedings
he's dead
your dog meat pal and it should be noted
that bill paxton is such a hardcore
staple of this universe because he's
gone toe-to-toe with both
extraterrestrials he's in predator 2 and
here's where i give gary busey loads of
credit for being a kinetic stalwart but
my sleeper pick of great human lead for
either franchise is danny glover and
predator 2. he had to follow in the
footsteps of an action icon in
schwarzenegger and what glover may lack
in handshake muscularity he makes up for
was smarts cunning and darren well the
guy even makes it all the way into a
predator spaceship he's one step away
from being will smith in independence
day okay
who's next prometheus piled on the
mythology and alien covenant gave us our
first chronological look at xenomorphs
in action but these prequels also gave
us more humans or humanoids to root for
or against it's complicated we got numi
rapace charlize theron idris elba guy
pierce catherine waterston danny
mcfreakin bride plus michael fassbender
is a robot named david that we so want
to trust like we did lance hendrickson's
incomparable bishop but davey ends up
going psycho and norman batesing the
alien creatures into existence the
humans also lose major points in these
two films for breaking the cardinal rule
of verses stop having sex in outer space
you're astronauts not drunk college kids
on spring break when all of humanity
could be at stake maybe have a hug and
save the copulation for your dorm room
back on earth damn kids predator now has
a shot to get on the scoreboard and
predators will help in a big way adrian
brody shocked the heck out of me when he
showed how much of a rip roaring action
hero he is alice braga was right there
keeping stride and my doppelganger
topher grace proved that he's gone light
years away from being that adorable eric
kid from that 70s show boyd holbrook
keegan michael key olivia munn and
company may not have been in the best
predator movie ever but they certainly
kept the action in the predator lively
and humorous shout outs to charles s
dutton and alien 3 and sanal lathan and
alien vs predator but overall the scope
of heroes anti-heroes villains and
all-out nut cases that can be loosely
categorized as human-like skews slightly
in favor of team predator for me
and thus they get the win in round three
we got us a ball game as it's two to one
alien
round four hunting season is open
okay yeah the title of this round is a
nod to one of my favorite action films
of all time hard target but there's a
good reason aliens and predators love
nothing more than hunting and since
they're not welcome at bass pro shops
i'll let them each show me what they got
in this round tools traits and abilities
will be key oh and also hard target
stars jean-claude van damme who is the
original casting to be the predator
creature in the 1987 debut but that was
scrapped due to his diminutive stature
and or the uncomfortability in his suit
you see he was sought after because of
his incredible martial arts moves but
they get tough to pull off in the hot
jungle in a rubber suit take after take
after take so instead director john
mctiernan went with seven foot two
behemoth kevin peter hall rumor also has
it the van damme was upset that he
wouldn't be seen in the film at all to
which i'm sure producers replied yeah we
know
you're an alien oh this guy's funny
anyway we miss an opportunity to see van
damme fight schwarzenegger but we still
got jean-claude taking on stallone at
the end of the expendables too so you
know that's something right all right
let's let these dogs hunt aliens make
for great stalkers and they can come at
you from a variety of different ways and
at a number of different times
throughout their existence you see they
all start out as eggs and then they
hatch into adorable little face huggers
ah they're so cute when they're babies
but much like feeding a mogwai after
midnight before long they'll turn into a
much more fearsome opponent the
facehugger latches onto another life
form's body by you know hugging the face
and implanting an egg inside the victim
that sucks but you can survive that part
for a while then later on it's not
heartburn you're experiencing it was not
that spicy big bite that's a xenomorph
popping out of your chest before it
leaps into a jaunty tune like hello my
baby hello my honey or at least that's
how i was lampooned in spaceballs when
john hurt once again got felt by his
nemesis
not again
these hatchlings will turn into full-on
xenomorphs who live for two things honor
thy queen and show off how much two
mouths can drool at the same time as
much as i didn't like alien 3 then or
now i will give props to the up close
and personal sequence where ripley is
attacked by a xenomorph who shows us
both mouths in full drool o vision that
is one scary creature and it makes for a
great hunter but to a predator
xenomorph's abilities just make it more
interesting game to hunt predators are
all about the sport of hunting and the
art of the kill they tend to go out on
the town in small packs but sometimes
even one individual predator has a few
too many beers and feels like you dive
into the jungle to tussle with earth's
finest they bring with them a stellar
array of weapons devices and abilities
like their invisibility cloaking and
their infrared vision which can pick up
any life form that's not currently
encased in mud besides their armor
predators have super strength quickness
and agility they can get you from high
in the trees they can chase you down on
land and once it gets to be physical
combat any daring human better have an
elaborate booby trap system in place
arnold barely survived kevin mcallister
might stand a chance hello
as one of the predators is lovingly
dubbed scar the xenomorphs are great
targets because they feature enhanced
defense mechanisms their blood is
dangerously acidic hence how uncle scar
got his nickname and it presents a rude
second act for any human that thought
they got the best of an alien imagine
finally killing an alien and then his
blood squirts in your face and now
you're done so too well that's great
that's just
great man we learned in the more recent
alien canon films that the xenomorphs
came to be courtesy of cyborg david
going cray-cray and making them with a
help from the engineers scary dark goo
while the origin story of the predator
is lesser known we do know that they
will always show up to a battle could be
deep in the jungle on the mean surface
streets of los angeles or on a far away
planet that serves as the perfect arena
for sport when it all comes down to it
what this round should be honoring isn't
just the survivalist nature of the
aliens or the warlike tribes of the
predators it's human being stan winston
and his effects team that is still
unrivaled in the annals of cinema
history winston helped create the og
predator and added his expertise to
james cameron's aliens standing on the
shoulders of folks like h.r geiger and
carl orombaldi who both won an oscar for
the special effects of alien in 1979 as
far as these two warrior species
themselves both hunt for survival but
the predators also enjoy the competitive
aspect of the sport they even have an
honor code sort of as evidence when a
samurai white death is awarded to a
worthy adversary towards the end of
predators which is again just one of the
many reasons why that movie kicks ass
looking good boss i don't feel like
tussling with either a xenomorph or a
predator but i at least know that the
xenomorphs their home planet is a long
long way from earth predators on the
other hand they love playing away games
and earth has become sort of like their
own lambeau field predator gets the win
in this round tying the ball game at two
to two and now the match all comes down
to this it's time for the wild card
round game over man it doesn't really
matter what era of video game you adhere
to when you see that failure screen
light up chances are you can also hear
hudson in your head channing his iconic
line game over man it's game over this
round will be all about the moments that
made these franchises special and we'll
be taking a highlight at least one from
each film in either series to generate a
decision and we're starting with the og
alien and this one's easy the kane chest
burst is so legendary mel brooks had to
lampoon it almost a decade later but it
still holds up as a worthy payoff to a
perfectly creepy pace the fun practical
effects the horror on john hurt's face
and also harry dean stan in another
scene works so well as a marriage of
horror and science fiction it also shows
us the genesis of a creature we're gonna
be seeing a whole lot more of in aliens
so whereas alien was more creepy and
crawly aliens is an all-out action
assault from a barge load of capable
soldiers there's big guns bigger egos
and the biggest xenomorphs that we'd
ever seen up to that point the human
cost was aplenty and major props the
bishop who may have been the most human
of us all bishop hey man or at least we
thought until that android was split in
half and he started leaking weird
spoiled milk everywhere who knew robots
were so gross 1987's predator has so
many moments of greatness a handful of
each from various celebrities in that
helicopter future governor jesse
ventura's toughness should be governor
carl weather's veteran leadership and
future governor arnold's everything if
it's quotes you like this is the movie
for you from the cia making action
jackson push too many pencils right
through the governator's quip insulting
the predator's um skin care regimen
the one-liners are almost as great as
the action itself predator 2 has some
solid gang violence sequences that a few
predators happen to get involved in but
the big winner in this film is danny
glover who defeats a predator in an
upset that sports fans would have to
liken to a 16 seed topping a one seed in
march madness and i'm sorry to bring up
bad memories uva fans but danny glover
was the university of maryland baltimore
county on that day everybody with me so
far
alien 3 um we know how i feel about it
it's kind of a bore fest with a few good
charles s dudden speeches but the last
hour of the film we're basically running
around closing garage doors on aliens
until ripley makes the ultimate
sacrifice to ensure that these aliens
are never a risk to us here on earth
it's an incredibly noble and i
appreciate her very on brand sacrifice
but the weak effects dull the impact for
me but i do love ellen ripley who
freshly shaved her head facing her foe
up close and personal one more time
alien resurrection added winona ryder
and ron perlman to the franchise but the
coolest part about this misfire was the
dead-on accuracy that the ripley clone
has shooting hoops
that's right of all the stuff that
happens in alien resurrection the best
part about it is that it still holds up
as one of the better intergalactic
basketball movies ever sorry space jam
predators is awesome throughout in case
you didn't know how i felt about that
movie and today my favorite sequence is
seeing the campsite of a gaggle of
predators hey they eat and drink and
sleep just like we do they're also so
tough that even danny trejo is relegated
to the role of a decoy and i just love
this whole movie's premise it's a planet
that we use as a game preserve it's fun
to watch not really a hoot to visit in
person the team of humans is as
quick-witted and rambunctious as ever in
the predator and we get to meet a super
predator who's somehow bigger and more
menacing than any of the others we've
ever met before meanwhile prometheus did
a great chunk of world building when it
didn't have you know scientists unable
to control their sexual desires what are
y'all living in the notebook settle down
take a cold shower and covenant reminded
us just how powerful xenomorphs can be
when one of them uses its noggin to
smash open a spaceship windshield safe
flight repair safe flight replace so for
about time thus far i do have to go back
to my favorite film in either canon easy
predators i love you but i'm talking
about aliens it marries the horror of
the first film with the best action of
any predator movie and despite the many
great quips featured in the first
predator flick the climax of aliens
takes the one-liner cake get away from
her you
ripley snarling get away from her you
beep while owning the load lifter is
simply one of the greatest walk-off
lines in movie history drop the mic fist
bump newt and accept your trophy as the
winner of this epic match of today on
verses it's aliens winning this round
and thus the match three to two and now
that i put that decision out into the
world it'll get beamed up into outer
space and it shouldn't be more than a
decade or so before predators discover
that i ruled against them and decide
that they're up for another earthling
hunt and i am no adrian brodie so i will
concede that i will squeal like a little
ham when they slice me up for a snack
but hey everyone and especially your
predators out there this is all just my
opinion it could change if either one of
y'all start cranking out great films
again and i would be the first in line
to see it so now it's your turn dear
viewer hit me up with your take on
social media at mark ellis live and be
sure to stay close to rotten tomatoes
for all the latest in the world of movie
predators tv and aliens you know you
always hear every so often that ridley
scott is itching for a crack at one more
so let's get this thing choggling that's
all for us today here on versus i'm your
host mark ellis and until next time i
promise my chest pains are strictly
related to
the spicy big bite i did have at 3am
last night i hope
[Music]